[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview your
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and broadcaster
Jenny cleeman and the political editor
of the Scottish son Rachel Watson so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now well the Metro leads
with the questions surrounding the BBC
chairman Richard Sharp's alleged
involvement in Boris Johnson's personal
finances before Mr Johnson recommended
him for the role both men deny any
wrongdoing
according to the eye energy companies
are poised to respond to a possible
government ban on the forcible
installation of prepayment meters in
people's homes by increasing their
prices
the star reports the boss of Tesco has
criticized food firms for charging too
much for household essentials
the male is unhappy at new findings
showing that a majority of households
receive more financial support from the
government than they pay in tax
the guardian has seen figures suggesting
that the UK government won't reach its
Target of generating a trillion pounds a
year from exports until 2035 some 15
years after the target date set by David
Cameron a decade ago
and the sun leads both what it calls a
paywall between the judges on the TV
show Britain's Got Talent
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Jenny keyman and Rachel Watson welcome
to both of you let us start with the
metro and uh this story their headliner
Boris Bank Chum and uh BBC in a bold
capitals there take us into this story
Jenny first of all explain it
uh well uh labor leading cause for an
investigation into the appointment of
Richard Sharp he's the chair of the BBC
the chair of the BBC is meant to ensure
the BBC's impartiality uphold its uh
Independence and there are allegations
in the Sunday Times that he helped Boris
Johnson secure a loan guarantee uh weeks
before Richard shop was chosen as uh as
a chair this is an appointment that the
Prime Minister has to okay when Boris
Johnson was a prime minister uh it was a
loan of up to 800 000 pounds the Sunday
Times was uh reporting and the question
is was uh the BBC job given to Richard
Shaw as uh to to return a favor to a
mate who helped uh dig Boris Johnson out
of a financial Hole uh Richard shop has
no editorial experience he doesn't have
experience in in journalism or in
program making he was a big donor to the
conservative party
um but you know the the role of BBC's
chair has always been a political
appointment Chris Patton who was also
former chair of the conservative party
was once BBC chairman uh so it's not
unusual that somebody uh in his position
uh with with links to uh the government
would be appointed in the role as BBC
chair Richard Sharp says he's done
nothing wrong and so does Boris Johnson
he's Richard shots denied a conflict of
interest but uh his uh involvement in
maybe helping Boris Johnson secure what
is reportedly a really massive loan
um wasn't disclosed when the panel was
deciding who should be BBC chair and it
it does smell quite fishy it's the sort
of thing that a few years ago uh would
attract a lot of attention but I fear
that after years of Boris Johnson's
government when we were just used to the
kind of smell of dodginess around his
dealings and the idea that uh maybe he
was getting help from very wealthy
people and people might be getting
things in return stories like this don't
really surprise people of course both
sides have of course said that they've
they've done uh nothing wrong but it is
an eye-popping story
yes and Boris Johnson last night uh via
a spokesperson saying that there was a
dinner in which uh Richard Sharp was in
attendance and the Canadian businessman
the distant relative actually of Boris
Johnson but finances were never
discussed Rachel
yeah and I think part of the problem
here is Jenny touched on it is the
perception around this and the lack of
transparency around the whole situation
and the fact that there wasn't a
disclosure at the time decisions were
made announcements were made and that is
a real headache for the Prime Minister
now
um because Boris Johnson is still an MP
he's still there despite no longer being
prime minister and there are questions
to answer about you know looking back on
that role but currently too and I think
this is
um as we said both men deny any
wrongdoing at all and and you know if
that is the case there is still um this
kind of
issue around it in fact it actually
looks bad and the perception of you know
the cost of living crisis people
struggling all across the country and
the huge sums of money potentially
involved in this
um and again this kind of cronyism
um claims around that that we've heard
repeatedly around the toys for the last
year or so now
um with covered contracts and then this
um questions again and labor and SNP
obviously calling for investigations
they want transparency and I think
there's you know there's legitimate
points there around the fact that this
has come out now and so long after a
process when
um the revolutions could have been made
at the time should there have been
um some disclosures from either party
um at the time Richard shark was
appointed and I think that is now one of
the big problems and a problem that the
conservatives have kind of let
themselves walk into time and time again
with problems rather than just
um it coming up people talking about it
and then and being able to move on from
it we get we get put in this kind of
Circle of
um scandal after scandal after Scandal
or potential scandal after Scandal and
then a lack of just dealing with the
problem at the time or or speaking up at
the time and that's that's what seems to
be going on here as well and Jenny this
at a time when the Nadeem zaharwee's tax
Affairs are still uh those are still
making the front pages of the newspapers
that the guardian I'm saying that his
political future appears to be under
increasing threat uh tonight again
yes well I think in any other era he
would be in disgrace and and he would
resign but I do think we have lost our
sense of honor and proportion after so
many years of a Boris Johnson government
uh I watched a bit of Sophie ridge's
interview uh with James cleverley uh
today it's quite remarkable way he was
saying he couldn't provide any more
details on on Nadeem zawi's tax Affairs
as he'd been busy over the weekend you
know if we recap on this uh this is uh
somebody who was Chancellor over the
summer who quite possibly when he was
Chancellor was negotiating a settlement
with hmrc uh for three million pounds
that he owed those 27 million pounds
that he received that he didn't pay tax
on he says he forgot to pay tax on it
and that it was an honest uh mistake but
there are so many questions raised in
all of this uh the biggest of all should
be why should we pay our taxes if if
ministers are avoiding it or able to
forget about it and get you know and not
face proper sanctions you know if
somebody who is chancellor over the
summer is able to get into this kind of
position why should any of us be
diligent about filing our tax returns
correctly the hypocrisy of this is
terrible and uh you know if somebody was
avoiding tax when he was Chancellor this
is incredibly big news you know he's
conservative chair the big thing in all
of this and also this this also um is is
relevant to the to the question of the
BBC chair and and Boris Johnson is that
Labor's attack line on Rishi sunak is
that he is weak uh and that he cannot
pull his uh ministers into line uh that
people will stay in post he can't
criticize Boris Johnson because Boris
Johnson has so many supporters still uh
within his party within his
parliamentary party he can't criticize
the deem zahari the question is when did
he know uh the Prime Minister said last
week that he he only found out when
anybody else did but he did appoint him
a cabinet minister supposedly Nadine
zahari was trying to settle this which
with hmrc in the summer so this this
doesn't look good for for the Prime
Minister considering that we know that
the labor party is just going to attack
him over and over again on the idea that
he stood outside ten Downing streets on
the day that he walked in claiming that
he was going to be a prime minister of
Integrity but he maybe does not have the
strength within his party uh to do the
right thing when it comes to the smell
of sleaze and Corruption yes and Rachel
labor directing their attack towards
demanding of the Prime Minister can
explain if he knew about the issue when
he appointed Nadeem zahawi to the
cabinet an interesting just on the
bottom of the Metro that that line a
chancellor who didn't know how to do his
tax return
uh it's uh embarrassing to say the least
yes it's incredibly embarrassing and
again a huge problem for the
conservative party and the Prime
Minister because again you know we are
talking about issues within the party
and issues that relate to ministers
people who are in these positions
positions of power and as was mentioned
he was Chancellor over the summer I mean
there's a number of questions here
obviously to be directed at the Prime
Minister when did he find out where
appointments made when he already had
knowledge of this but also on Nadim
zahawi um you know questions around when
was this settled exactly specific dates
labor won all the correspondence between
nadims of Howie and the hmrc and I think
these are things that are really
important because as was mentioned he
was Chancellor
um over the summer and if it happened
during that specific time you know where
penalties paid again it was suggested in
um the garden I think it was that there
were there was a penalty so I think all
these things and again it's a huge
transparency issue because the longer
that you go without addressing these
questions without answering them and
trying to kind of block it or issue
statements that don't really address the
the kind of Crux of the issue the longer
it will drag out and we saw that with
partygate for example the longer at
Boris Johnson's prime minister at the
time tried to kind of hold back and push
back against this or just not say
anything and the more we find out the
more that that was dripped out in the
papers every week the more people who
were coming forward with it and I think
um you know it's just so the
conservatives don't learn their lesson
when it comes to these things as well
meanwhile Jenny according to the mail
Boris Johnson is uh in Ukraine at the
moment
yes it is strange how much more
comfortable he looks in in Ukraine uh
than he does sometimes in the UK or
certainly when it comes to um answering
questions he's a hero in Ukraine because
of the support that uh the UK government
uh has given Ukraine over the past year
and him being such a kind of big
figurehead uh for that support uh
zelenski and him clearly get on very
well uh but it is it's a symbolic thing
um you know I I'm always pleased
whenever I see Ukraine still on the
front pages and still in the headlines
it is not yet a year since the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and and you know we
need to remember
um you know the struggle that everybody
in Ukraine continues to to go through on
a daily basis after being uh invaded But
I think you know Boris Johnson is very
concerned about his
um status on the global stage he wants
to portray himself as a kind of global
Statesman he is traveling the world
giving very highly paid speeches this is
all part of that if I was uh somebody
living in Uxbridge I might be a bit
annoyed that he perhaps wasn't doing
more to represent my interests at home
but this is where he's most comfortable
on the global stage yeah so we mustn't
forget that uh he did say on his uh
leaving Asta La Vista Jenny and Rachel
for the moment thank you we are going to
take a break coming up do food companies
deserve blame for supermarket food
prices the boss of Tesco apparently
thinks so we'll discuss that and more
next
[Music]
foreign
and Rachel Watson or they will be there
they are
um let's have a look at the eye and this
story about the energy firm seemingly
hitting back at the business secretary
ordering companies to stop forcibly
installing prepayment meters they're
saying as a result they will have to put
the prices up Rachel
yeah I think this is a story that
doesn't look you know particularly good
for energy companies we are still in
this cost of living crisis and there
doesn't like to be really any end even
when you look for those stories that
might suggest that uh you know the cost
of living crisis and inflation might a
recession might not be as long as uh as
expected and there's not much positive
news out there about the economy and the
impact that has on people's lives and I
think as you say this story is talking
about energy companies hitting back at
the business secretary who is ordering
them not to or to stop forcibly
installing prepaid meters for people who
have been unable to afford their energy
bills and they're warning that if they
don't do this people will go into debt
there will be huge
um debt bills
um that are stacked up for people and
leading to concern that they would then
have to put their prices up for for
other people and I think
um as I said we're still in this cost of
living crisis we know that the support
for energy bills across the country is
going to change that's not going to be
at the levels that it has been over the
last few months and the cap on energy
bills
is going to rise again and people are
already worried about that you know you
talk to people who are struggling we've
just come out of the Christmas period
and it is very cold at the moment so
people have tried not to put their
heating on but you know that's
unsustainable you can't live
um without your heating and so many
parts of the country when it's this cold
we know the weather is going to get
colder so it's a real worry for people
and I think
um this is a particularly bad Loop when
you think that if people can't if you
install prepaid materials and people
can't afford it they have no power and
then that's a huge issue for a families
up and down the country
uh but Jenny on the the other side of
the argument uh the energy firms do have
a point that if these prepayment meters
aren't installed that the debts will
soar
yes but we know that these energy
companies are experiencing record
profits at the moment and we also know
that the sort of people who use
prepayment meters or that these meters
will be installed in the homes of
they're the people who spend the
greatest proportion of their income on
on Heating and you know this has been
called disconnection by the back door
that's what this is that's basically
saying to the people who are most
vulnerable whose lives are most
precarious whose Finance is most
precarious
um that they're going to have their
energy cut off at a time uh when yeah
when it's incredibly cold so um you know
it does suggest that this is a kind of
profiteering really of course people
have to pay for their energy but for the
for the people who uh can least afford
it um you know this kind of front page
is is going to be very worrying reading
and from Energy prices to food prices we
look at the front page of the star and
the Tesco bosses saying that food firms
are a challenginger too much there as as
well Rachel
yes this came from an interview this
morning that the chairman of Tesco John
Allen done where he suggested that some
food firms may be using inflation as a
way to as an excuse to hike prices
further than is necessary and you know
we've just spoken about the price of
energy and people struggling and
vulnerable households struggling with
that we're also it's really
um more remarkable how much prices and
shots are gone up the the basics those
kind of Staples that people need to buy
and I think you know this is um
incredibly scary reading for some people
who are already kind of pushed to their
limits and the fact that some businesses
could be using inflation as a way to
hike prices further and I think that was
a really Stark Revelation this morning
and a really concerning comments
actually and he spoke about how Tesco
were were looking to identify this as
closely as possible they were looking
they have a team of people who are
looking to try and identify if this is
happening and ways to ways to stop it
because
um you know there are on the front line
they will be seeing customers um who are
who are struggling and I think it makes
for security meeting actually yeah and
again the Tesco boss John Allen saying
that uh the food funds are simply greedy
because they're making huge profits
Jenny
yes and also we know that when uh
inflation slows or stops the prices are
not actually going to go down that's the
thing they're just going to stop going
up so the idea that food companies are
going to be profiteering at a time when
we're all feeling the pinch so much um
is particularly depressing I think let's
just quickly round off with the Metro is
there better economic news around the
corner Rachel
yeah so it makes it feel like that when
you read this through the Metro at first
that the recession
um won't be as long as some
um economic experts have suggested but
they do talk about it being twice as bad
and so there's the salt there there's
that pinch of salt and the tiniest
little bit of Hope potentially that
although it's going to be twice as bad
double as bad as what some people had
previously forecasted the recession
won't last quite as long
um so you know you look for some good
news but it's off it's it's balanced out
with with the bad too
Jenny very quickly do we take any
comfort from that
I have to say I took comfort from the
headline and then I read the first line
of this piece recession will be twice as
bad as the economists predict and if we
if we're meant to feel happy by an
article like that then I feel very sorry
for us yeah I feel very sorry I think I
think we'll feel happy if we just read
the headline and stop there uh Jenny and
Rachel for the moment thank you